[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum kurzen
nachrichten überblick in der
halbzeitpause wir beginnen mit nikon
durch die virusvariante gehen die
infektionszahlen rasant nach oben viele
fragen sich habe ich mich infiziert die
labore aber sind am limit die
entscheidung des bund länder treffen
gestern daher künftig per pcr vorrangig
etwa medizinisches und pflegepersonal zu
testen kommt bei vielen nicht gut an
thomas korn sehr über die kritik
gut besser pcr tests der goldstandard er
ist bald nicht mehr für alle da etwa für
sie nicht menschen die angehörige
pflegen 5 millionen sind das sagt die
stiftung patientenschutz
lebensgefährlich wenn sie
pflegebedürftige anstecken auch sie
haben keinen anspruch per se
lehrpersonal und lernende ungerecht und
unsinnig so die kritik einerseits sollen
schulen offen bleiben wenn es dann aber
wirklich darauf ankommt ihnen priorität
einzuräumen etwa bei der verteilung von
pcr tests dann fallen schulen immer
hinten über weitere befürchtung testet
man nicht alle verdachtsfälle genau muss
man sozusagen abstriche machen bei der
statistik aber hat man die pandemie dann
noch im griff auch deshalb fordert die
opposition dass pcr-test
breit verfügbar stand jetzt wird's eng
wöchentlich schaffen die labore maximal
2,8 millionen pcr tests vergangene woche
machten sie mehr als 25 millionen die
auslastung also gut 90 prozent
werden noch mehr tests gebraucht dann
wollen die labore frühzeitige ansagen
wie hoch der bedarf sein soll bis zu
welcher zeit und wie ver fahren wir wenn
die kapazitäten gar nicht gebraucht
werden denn auf den kosten möchte man
nicht sitzen bleiben langfristig planen
den durchblick behalten der wunsch
vieler nach rund zwei jahren pandemie
blicken wir auf die aktuell weiter
steigenden corona zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 126
1955 neu infektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 52
1550 mehr als vergangenen dienstag
214 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incident steigt auf 8
194,3
empörung bei der cdu der chef der
erzkonservativen werte union max otte
kandidiert für das amt des
bundespräsidenten und zwar auf vorschlag
der afd die cdu reagiert entrüstet und
will ihn jetzt aus der partei
ausschließen in berlin stellte die afg
am nachmittag otto offiziell als ihren
kandidaten vor er sagte seine
nominierung sei eine große ehre und er
sehe kein widerspruch zu seiner cdu
mitgliedschaft
zur stunde berät der cdu-bundesvorstand
theo koll kommt ein
parteiausschlussverfahren ja das kann
ich sagen ich habe gerade aus der
sitzung gehört dass der bundesvorstand
einstimmig entschieden hat ein
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen max otte
einzuleiten wobei das ja ein zäher
prozess werden könnte die spd hat wir
erinnern uns viele jahre gebraucht um
thilo sarrazin auszuschließen
armin laschet nannte es heute eine
schande des ortes sich von der afg habe
aufstellen lassen und es ist glaube ich
nicht ganz abwegig diese ganze
kandidatur als einen kalkulierten
schachzug zu betrachten mit dem die afd
die cdu provozieren will nach dem motto
ihr stimmt für den sozialdemokraten
steinmeier aber wir stellen einen eurer
erz konservativen als kandidatin auf
vorbei der zweite fdp chef jörg deuten
uns gesagt hat er halte die kandidatur
ortes für falsch und für strategisch
unklug und damit wäre dann der keil er
in die afg getrieben worden danke für
diese einordnung theo koll
die frühere spd vorsitzende und
ehemalige arbeitsministerin andrea
nahles soll neue chefin der
bundesagentur für arbeit werden darauf
haben sich arbeitgeber und
gewerkschaften geeinigt die
bundesregierung muss noch zustimmen
besonders beschäftigt die
bundesregierung zurzeit die ukraine
krise kaum ein tag ohne diplomatische
gespräche
zur stunde empfängt der kanzler in
berlin den französischen präsidenten sie
wollen sich abstimmen über einen weg der
deeskalation dem makro dann in den
verkommenen tagen russlands präsident
putin vorschlagen will frank buchwald
über die sorge vor einem krieg üben für
den ernstfall freiwillige in kiew die
ukraine gibt sich verteidigungsbereich
zugleich diplomatie in berlin
frankreichs präsident beim bundeskanzler
kissel schießt und sich geht es um
deeskalation im rahmen der nato der eu
und natürlich in unserer gemeinsamen
verantwortung enorm only vollmacht die
du noch und ich solche gespräche
zwischen der ukraine und russland sollen
morgen wieder beginnen begleitet von
deutschland und frankreich
wir erwarten auch von russland deshalb
eindeutige schritte die zu einer
deeskalation der situation beitragen und
wir sind uns alle einig dass eine
militärische aggression schwerwiegende
konsequenzen
nach sich zöge gestern hatte us
präsident biden sich eingeschaltet
telefon diplomatie mit den europäern
zusätzlich versetzen die amerikaner 8500
soldaten in alarmbereitschaft und der
ukrainische botschafter bittet berlin um
hilfe und die ukraine wollen ihre
unabhängigkeit nicht verlieren das ist
für uns das höchste gut wir stehen da
alleine wir haben das recht auf
selbstverteidigung russische soldaten an
der grenze zur ukraine manuell verheißt
es offiziell aber sieht sehr ernst aus
der druck auf den britischen
premierminister johnson im weiter zu
jetzt hat die londoner polizei
ermittlungen aufgenommen wegen partys
die im amtssitz von johnson gefeiert
wurden während des lok downs im jahr
2020 sie untersuche potenzielle verstöße
gegen die korona auflagen so die polizei
nach dem amoklauf an der universität in
heidelberg sind noch viele fragen offen
vor allem die nach dem motiv fest steht
der 18-jährige tatverdächtige ein
student der biowissenschaften war nicht
vorbestraft kurz vor der tat seiner per
web angekündigt haben dass leute
bestraft werden in einem hörsaal hatte
er das feuer eröffnet drei menschen
wurden leicht verletzt eine junge frau
starb nach einem kopfschuss der schütze
hat sich selbst umgebracht
das heute-journal können sie um 21 50
seen mit marietta slomka und jetzt
geht's hier weiter mit dem wetter und
der handball-em bis morgen dann wiederum
sehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute nacht fällt etwas
regen nordöstlich der elbe sonst ist es
meist bedeckt und im süden auch mal klar
da bildet sich nebel am alpenrand sinken
die temperaturen bis minus 7 grad im
norden bleibt es etwas milder und morgen
liegen dann die höchsttemperaturen
zwischen minus ein und plus sieben grad
häufig ist es trüb in der nordhälfte tut
sich die sonne wirklich schwer da kann
es auch noch ein bisschen diesel regen
geben deutlich mehr sonnenschein gibt es
hier im südwesten außerhalb und oberhalb
des nebels besonders am alpenrand und
dann ändert sich das wetter es kommen
sturmtiefs heran es wird auch ein
bisschen kälter und dann fällt am
freitag schnee am alpenrand guten abend